we're huge fans thank you so much we've
been fine since you had hair oh thank
you hey it's a choice damn good one -
thanks guys yep we're wrestlers as well
actually where she didn't the tryouts
today oh cool what advice would you give
us if if we want to win over the crowd
and it went over the crowd what are your
names good my name it doesn't matter
what your names are you walk around here
interrupting the rock you like you
haven't seen the Sun in 20 years you
like you just stepped out of Oliver
Twist please sir may have some more
advice you want some advice here sir
octopi shut your mouth or you want what
you want I don't know what the rock
wants the rock wants you to go out there
take no prisoners have no regrets have
no fear lay it all out on the line
because if you don't do that the rock is
gonna find your friend Mary Poppins he's
gonna take her umbrella yeah he's gonna
shine it up real nice he's gonna turn
that sumbitch sideways and stick it
straight up your candy asses
there's your advice straight out up
there to brownie beating pie-eating
trailblazing I'm not raising
entertaining the glove never hotter
chuck it into rejects from Harry Potter
so that's how you went over the crowd
[Laughter]
hello yeah I'm gonna put your speaker
for a second
yeah April we're bringing smackdown to
the o2 in London and we'd like both of
you to come down and try out for us
hello dad be very happy to accept good
and we already have a Brittany so just
think of an alternative name yeah sure
okay don't thank you so much yeah yeah
thank you thank you very much sir I told
you it was a given sorry what is the WWE
oh bloody Oh defeat you're doing you
really want to choke around you think
this yeah pretty tight
in trouble a way I know you you're from
that weird family aren't you we're not
weird we don't like wrestling how do you
know if you've never been I've never had
back to a bleeding before but I'm pretty
sure I'm not fine about how about I
shove her head up your ass then we can
find out anyways
sorry about that rock four huge fans
thank you so much more advice would you
give us we want to be the next you what
are your names get mining it doesn't
matter what your names are you walk
around here interrupting the rock you
like you haven't seen the Sun in 20
years you like you just stepped out of
Oliver Twist please sir may have some
more advice you want some advice here's
the rocks biceps your mouth
thanks Dwayne got it good morning
wrestling nerds well this is where we
see whether or not you get to go on to
WWE this is our short thud hello why do
you want a wrestle I'm the toughest
bastard in any room
probably shouldn't swear I wonder if
ladies present sorry miss sorry about
that I call your name that means you'll
be coming with me to Florida Paige thank
you all very much
you have to take my brother no one
deserves this more than Zach I wish you
the best son this is the end of the line
for you do you know what it's like to
one thing in life and then your own
sister takes it away from you it was my
dream to
who wants this to be out there you're
not just doing this view you're doing it
for the family
Paige I myself have come from a
wrestling family too I know exactly what
it means to you don't worry about being
the next me be the first you
what mr. Wayne Johnson how are you prove
it is cookin
yeah and I'm Vin Diesel might I'm sorry
[Applause]
you